bonsoir mesdames et messieurs un sujet
vraiment fascinant pour commencer ce
bulletin comment compliqué quelque chose
qui devait être simple en principe c'est
à dire un service d'autobus rapides sur
pie-ix pour rendre évidemment la plus
fluo et de la circulation nord sud
ça devait être fait en 2013 ensuite en
2017 2020 on cible maintenant 2022
davide gentile et on justifie ce nouveau
un report en disant qu'il faut
complètement reconstruire le boulevard
sur 8 km donc il ya deux éléments
principaux patrice dans ce qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui d'avoir effectivement comme
vous l'avez mentionné le rapport
justement quand tu es la finalisation de
saint servais finale à 2022
et on nous dit au plus tôt dans les
documents que j'ai obtenu un peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui et ensuite on confirme
aussi qu'il sera impossible
d'électrifier donc cette option là
d'électrification des futurs autobus est
mise de côté leurs rapports patrice
pourquoi eh bien il serait dû selon
plusieurs sources aux tergiversations
quant à l'électrification
mais il ne serait surtout due au fait
que tout est à reconstruire
sur les 8 km du tronçon de pie-ix on
pense entre autres aux égouts à la
chaussée osaka dieu qu on s'est donc dit
du côté des autorités que t'as qu'à
reconstruire valait mieux si je peux
dire donner un grand coup est ce que les
citoyens sont inquiets de cette énième
report on écoute quelques réactions
glanées un peu plus tôt la serbe est
on nous promet encore empreint du faux
suspense à chaque compte 10 toujours
tardieu est radieuse
je pense pas vraiment à une grosse
génération
si ça marche oui c'est nécessaire c'est
ça qu'il faut voir la circulation est
tout autre dans ce jeu a pas beaucoup
qu'on doit faire ça et vous en avez
parlé david rapidement le monde a fait
des sommets il ya quelques semaines sur
l'électrification des transports aux on
s'en va vers l' or ça ne sera même pas
des autobus électriques
ouais et justement dans une réaction est
mise il ya quelques minutes la ville de
montréal s'étonne justement du fait
qu'on écarte cette idée là surtout
effectivement que le gouvernement a
lancé une stratégie dans ce sens là il y
a à peine deux semaines pour conclure
patrice vous dire que pour pallier
justement à l'énorme chantier cet autre
énorme chantier qui s'annonce pour les
montréalais l'administration considère
de d'instaurer un tronçon une voie une
voie réservée permanente à partir de
2017 pour justement tenter d'harmoniser
les inconvénients ils seront si nombreux
que la veille de montréal songe déjà à
élaborer un plan de communication pour
convaincre les citoyens de bien fondé de
ce projet et les inciter à être à
nouveau patient mais voilà merci david
bonne soirée